je ne sais pas si vous avez vu cette
publicité du gouvernement du québec cet
automne et 60 minutes d'activité
physique par jour sur leur fortune
mesa même dans le bulletin catherine
st-pierre
elle l'a vu est elle mieux écrit 60
minutes d'activité par jour alloués aux
élèves
où quand comment je n'ai vu cela dans
zoo qu'un regard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait
comprendre dans la pub les élèves des
écoles primaires au québec ont
actuellement deux heures d'éducation
physique par semaine
par contre on est en train d'implanter
un nouveau programme
tous les jours ils devront faire une
heure d'activité physique
les cours d'éthique ils sont pas si l'on
sait il y aura potes de personnel
supplémentaire qui sera embauchée
ce sont les profs et les gens du service
de garde devront s'assurer que les
jeunes font 15 minutes d'activité quatre
fois par jour
ça peut se faire lorsqu'ils arrivent le
matin pendant les récréations sur
l'heure du midi ou en classe par exemple
un enseignant pourraient décider de
faire 15 minutes de yoga
après et coiffé d'une rivale fait que
celle du conte ici l'école saint-arsène
à montréal va recevoir 15 mille dollars
soixante dix pour cent de la somme pour
la formation du personnel ou la location
de lieux 20% pour de l'achat de matériel
sportif 10% pour du transport vers des
lieux de plein air il ya un problème par
contre avec l'argent des écoles se sont
fait dire que c'est pour trois ans
seulement il ya des fonds disponibles
seulement pour 900 écoles soit à peu
près une école primaire sur deux donc
pourquoi 60 minutes
en fait c'est la recommandation de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
les spécialistes disent même que 15 à 20
minutes d'activité modérée ou intense
sans un impact sur l'apprentissage au
cours de l'heure où leurs ennemis qui
sut si comme 85e on voulait qu'on
vérifie quelque chose